let's take some phone calls our number
is 6 1 7 8 30 40 750 we will go to our
first caller from the 407 area code
caller what's your name and where are
you calling from didn't he get you okay
so I threw out that first time calling
in my name is Dakota I'm from Orlando
Florida great what's on your mind so I
was wondering a lot here on the Left
argue for reduced defense spending and
I'm one of them actually and and often
when if I bring us up to people who
disagree with me they they bring up the
fact that the defense spending is lower
is high on the discretionary spending
but not on the overall budget I was
wondering what sort of counter response
you would have to something to that well
my response would be who cares what
difference does that make the point is
we should be spending less on defense
we've got you know 4050 military bases
in Germany would we be just as safe with
only 20 military bases in Germany I
think it's hard to argue that that we
wouldn't so I think I would say you know
that that's a very technical argument
and it doesn't really change the reality
of the insane amount that we spend on
defense we have all sorts of weapons and
ordinance that basically has an
expiration date on it which we
eventually just throw out and order new
stuff from defense contractors and and
all of these arrangements that are
really not necessary to keep us safe so
I would tell somebody that arguing about
it in terms of which budget it appears
on is really an irrelevant distraction
right I agree it just normally when I
bring that up they bring up the fact
that we spend more unlike I think we
send more on things like Social Security
and Medicare and Medicaid yeah and say
that we happily we should we're getting
a lot out of those and we're wasting I
agree on definitely a great oceans I
appreciate the call you've got done a
very strange noises going on in the back
I'm going to let you go I really do
appreciate the call some almost sounds
like he was calling from a spa or
something like that there was a spawn
music in the background there